sean astin hello Sean my god what's her
name I was here before I think you were
and right in this chair when I was here
hi everybody oh you know I just Wyclef
Jean is that right when he was about to
run for president
how did Haiti I think he withdrew I
think he didn't go very far but I gave
him some great political advice before
he quit what what what show was it what
show I don't know but it was this chair
I swear it was it was well widely it was
it Opie and Anthony no no no no no it
was when the Haiti thing I mean it was
like mm no oh yeah it might be an
afternoon long after the show man you uh
you must that was an entrance was great
yeah we could Wyclef we were trying to
figure out how we segue into him we can
just go right there you must be loving
the response you're getting on stranger
things it's awesome yeah that's awesome
really fun not just for me but you know
we're my oldest kids at college and our
two younger kids 15 and 12 we're like
you know it's really special for them
that we sit and we talk and we you know
my 12 year old binge did and then we
talked about it all and you know we get
to yeah that's pretty cool they're
excited about some of the press and
stuff as well have you been in Hollywood
I was born there I was born in Hollywood
my parents are sort of legendary
actually who I said yes I did
oh yeah was this ear sorry um so my mom
is Patty Duke who won an Oscar when she
was 14 for playing Helen Keller and the
miracle worker and my dad is John Astin
who was well he was gomez in the Addams
Family the original Islander but he was
also one of the Riddler's in the
television panel man so but they anyhow
so so was I so I was you know in the
bosom so you see you've been familiar
with that stuff so were you talking
about all this others hat with Corey
Feldman and stuff you were there and saw
that your whole life saw what whenever
whatever has been happening in Hollywood
yeah yeah of course my friend I've been
talking to a lot lately people give him
a lot of [ __ ] lately do you think
they're right or wrong to say hey you
should have named people receiver like
right to kind of go well like 10 million
dollars is a lot of money
there's a lot of issues to separate out
with that first and foremost as he was
abused as a child and that gives him an
awful lot of room to express himself and
develop himself and he's got his whole
rationale and there's he's been in so
many interviews lately and and you know
he should he should speak for himself
about how he how and why and who he
talks about things but I think it's
unfolding I think it's unfolding well
you know I think he's legitimately
opened himself up for criticism because
of the overlap between personal gain and
a crusade to help other people but at
the same time a lot of people who
support him don't care they they they
they want to see what he does they want
to see if he can actually help people so
as his friend I kind of have a sober I'm
like it's auntie I'm like are you eating
are you getting enough sleep you know
and and he um he's you know he's he's
doing what he believes is the right
thing to do and people can we'll see you
know how party I'm sorry saying how far
do you think this will go like I know
there's probably a lot of people who are
nervous like oh [ __ ] I'm next like like
you know I mean how well that's what's
happened that's why Cory is he's been on
this thing for his whole life since he
was you know 14 or 15 he's been pursuing
this kind of oh I don't know what you
say this you know catharsis for himself
and and this sense of you know need for
justice and like wanting to help other
people and everything else but it's
because of the whole Harvey Weinstein me
to watershed moment in American culture
where all of a sudden you know talking
about how we interact with with each
other you know between the genders and
stuff like it's it's galactic what's
happening so that's why he has a new
thing let me I'll share one thing that I
you know my daughter my oldest daughters
in college at Harvard and we were so
excited to get her set up there and we
went back and she's a junior now but we
went back and we we got her in her dorm
room it was so exciting for us and I
went and visited her a couple months
after she had been there and we got to
talking and it was clear she's a tough
girl you know she's she's she's
did a lot of high school or high school
experience was she was cheerleader she
was mock-trial she was in drama she was
like no there was no grass growing under
her feet she was not a Wallflower she
said go out and get him kind of a
student and athlete like that kind of
thing she was scared she's like dad you
don't understand when I want from this
building to that classroom I'm passing a
bunch of places where I'm a target
people whistle and holler at me people
to all kinds of things and and what are
this as a father all of a sudden I felt
like somebody was pouring hot water on
me like a bucket of hot water going down
my body and I'm like oh my god I have
absolutely failed I failed as a father I
failed as a man I failed as a citizen I
failed as a kind of an entity in the in
the in the world because that's how
women feel all the time everywhere they
go that's not okay why is that your
failure it's all our failure because
it's my kid and she felt that way and if
she's feeling that way then it's my
fault because she's my kid is mine I
take as my personal responsibility to
make sure she's safe and she's okay and
she feels strong you think that we
haven't created I'm willing to women do
deal with a bunch of [ __ ] that we don't
see like just getting like I don't get
catcalled or I don't have the Menace of
the guys in a fort no you I mean sit is
surprising sometimes bigger fellas do
but it's scary to like to think like hey
the only reason I'm not being [ __ ]
right now is because this stronger
person is choosing not to like that's a
scary way to that's what I'm saying
that's not the only reason probably
that's my girl and a guy that they don't
know each other and what's going on in
that moment when they're just standing
watching the thing go from four to three
to two to one what's what's the energy
do they really feel like fine and
comfortable and totally centered and
safe or is there a little bit of energy
and the fact is that like human
sexuality is just not talked about and
in a way that is you know the kamasutra
we are we need the American kamasutra so
we can't because sex is great and and
flirting is great and interacting with
each other and you know
but if you do it absent a respect and
appreciation for how the other person
feels and you're kind of a dick so
what's your what's been your experience
in Hollywood because you've been there
in huge positions kind of all throughout
your life right like every every stage
of your life you've got some giant movie
role at least one if not multiple pretty
giant nigh conic roles I've been
insulated my whole most of my almost all
my I've been married 26 years when
together with my wife twenty-seven and a
half years so that's a that's a center
you know I mean and in terms of it's a
big question like you turned an arrow an
arrow will so have you because from an
outsider's perspective I would imagine
that you've managed to avoid a lot of
the pitfalls specifically as a kid like
you you don't hear that was never abused
I was never I never got into drugs and
alcohol not not too much alcohol drink a
little bit but but never like you know
never try and contrive never like and is
that because if you're your parents is
that because like you know after the
Goonies yours biggest stars Corey
Feldman in that moment as a kid you're
the star that move Corey's talked a lot
about it so I can refer to it but it's
really up for court he say for himself
but like watching him on the set of
Goonies and the lack of parental care
for him was horrifying I think and it
was and we all loved and cared about him
but there's like only so much you can do
protect I mean he was a cocky kid he was
strong-willed and you know had a lot of
energy and was doing things and I don't
know that you know in a certain moment
you can go hey Corey I want to talk to
you about the lack of parental
supervision you have and let's see how
that's gonna affect your life and you
know in five years you're gonna get
arrested for you know especially when
you're into heroin in your car yeah when
your kid well anybody yeah for no one
isn't a successful Enterprise to do that
I mean maybe maybe certain people can
have that influence and I regret that I
that I maybe couldn't have been more of
that to him or something but but um but
he you know but that's that's a big
that's and then there's there's you know
genetic predilections to things and I
just got lucky I have parents who love
me I parents who cared about me I had a
father whose expectations of me were
really kind of specific you know he
really wanted me to go to college make
sure I went
College even if I got to act in shows he
really just wanted me to get that
diploma and have that experience and it
was probably actually on that level is
probably great that there was so much
show business in your family because
like when you're a kid and you get this
giant movie there's not this thing that
sweeps over your parents like oh my god
our kid is a star our kids in a movie
they understand I when Lord of the Rings
came out I was definitely not prepared
really I was definitely it was too
overwhelming was this totally
overwhelming and I'll I definitely lost
my Center and self several times I don't
know how it expressed itself like what
not drugs or you know that kind of thing
or but it was definitely like my just
because it was so big or just because in
at that point in your life you didn't
think there was another one or I think
because my ambition was so big like you
know when you ask a kid where they want
to be when they grow up like I wanted to
be President the United States I wanted
to be the CEO of a billion-dollar
corporation I wanted to be like a
filmmaker like David Lean like there's
no there were no small ambitions and as
soon as Lord of the Rings hit it was
like world's your oyster what are you
gonna do right and like I didn't know
how to choose and also because I had
gotten really really fat and and when
you get really fat you've never been
really felt like really fat let me say
my eyes was the fat Hobbit the stinking
fat out of it and it's just awesome
every time he says I really do get mad
at him but but um like losing I lost
weight again and like I don't know man
it just I just pray miss and you're
famous and good-looking and but like
this whole thing was happening it it
just you know you'd look around and
you'd see like Orlando Bloom gorgeous
yeah guy Yeah right and and saying he
went from a guy who nobody had ever
heard of him to like you know heartthrob
of this hearthrob of the century and
then Elijah who done movie after movie
after movie with really talented like he
was the lead and all these way more than
I ever did yeah and like how did he
manage his career and and just looking
around I had a wife and a kid it was a
part of it was the money actually I
didn't get paid very well for Lord of
the Rings bitterness no no not
bitterness just like oh we have to sell
our house now what are you gonna do like
these you have to say it house I had to
sell my house afterwards what happened
was the
we lived in a lovely two-bedroom
two-bath house better yeah in in Sherman
Oaks in the flats so you know you can
always hear the helicopters police
helicopters at night like but there's
still a nice little backyard and you
know we could have we could have lived
forever there and would have been fine
but I wanted to get a bigger place so we
bought a house up in the hills with a
view and the business manager said to me
you have to make 250 grand a year based
on how you spend your money if you don't
increase your expenditures in like a lot
of other areas of you thank you very
much if you just live your life just
like this but with the new mortgage and
the new insurance and all that you have
to make two hundred fifty thousand a
year and I was like I've been in college
for four years at UCLA and I was like
there's no problem I can absolutely make
250 grand a year you know so I then I
got did the audition process and got
offered Lord of the Rings and it was an
offer for two hundred fifty thousand for
a year and a half and I was like wait a
minute I'm like my Penn signed this
contract which obligated me to 250 a
year and I'm gonna sign this contract
which will make it so that I cannot
satisfy that other thing yeah so it was
75 grand a movie I wrote a book actually
75 grand in movie weighs what you got
yeah Wow
yeah and how about residuals for that
for the no residuals merged oh my god
Mertz yes a little bit of merch a little
bit of merch but still it's not lawyer I
love my lawyer he was like during the
contract phase I just couldn't believe
it was gonna be so little I'm like you
know I've made tons more money of this
on an individual film and this is like a
galactic movie but why is that because
they know that everyone just wants this
role like it's a power it's uh why don't
you call Donald Trump he can tell you
it's about negotiating when you want
them more than they want you you're in a
good spot um could you live could you
have renegotiated for like no you're in
a bad spot you know we did them all at
one time but we don't I see so you don't
know that the we agreed not to talk
about it but when we came time to do
publicity for the third film you know
like I was feeling a little bit better
is that a good way to get around why did
they did they take carry a little bit
well we're not supposed to talk about
that particular thing but yes yeah you
weren't such a bad spot anymore
yeah we yeah well but I then by then I'd
done a lot of other work and we were
fine
it's not that big a deal like you can
I'm not asking for any way to feel sorry
because of money but but at that moment
right when I was fat trying to get
skinny when I going from being in
college now to having have this
incredible experience to now it's gonna
be like globally famous am I gonna be
the one that they're gonna invite to do
all the serious radio shows am I gonna
be like where do I stack up and the the
23 great actors who are in there right
am I on the poster do I like I just
didn't there's no like rulebook you know
you guys sit around and analyze this
stuff all day long you could probably
make a lot of money like advising people
who pop you know who have something that
comes out you can be like this is the
kind of things you need to know there
was no even though I had all that
experience of my with my you know family
and everything and my young success and
everything it was there was nothing I
was in the I got appointed to a
presidential Council I was in the Oval
Office with President Bush I mean like
there was literally no place you
couldn't go and you like him were they
starting off did you like him more than
you thought you would when you met him
people say that regardless of the
politician you meet a guy like that you
like him more than I absolutely liked
him more meeting him I mean you know I'm
still I still think I don't know if he's
a war criminal for going into Iraq under
false pretenses but when he shook my
hand this is what I said he was standing
on the seal of the Oval Office and I
weighed the way they do it is you you
all the people on the panel are in a
line and then they the I don't know who
it is Stewart or somebody like announces
you Sean Astin whatever and then you
step on there you shake hands you have a
moment maybe a word or two you turn and
take a picture and then you go step to
the other side and he does that through
the whole line that gives the speech
okay so so all I could think was I have
every right as a citizen of this great
land to be standing on that seal because
he didn't win that election he was
installed as a president but he has the
power and I respect the office and I
respect the fact that this guy figured
out how to get power and he said so I
was like when I walk onto that seal and
shake his hand it's not going to be it
with like glowing sure whatever I'm
gonna shake his hand and look him in the
eye and and say nice to meet you sir
you're like that's what I'm gonna do
so I shook his hand and his dad I said
to him your father appointed my mother
as one of the thousand points of light
remember the Dana Carvey think that was
born to light yeah yeah so my mom was
one of those thousand points of light
that's first I went to the White House
is when she was being recognized at the
Kennedy Center or whatever
so I said I stood I go you're fine we
shook hands harder I looked him right in
the eye I said your father appointed my
mom was one of the thousand points of
light and without a blink he goes then
we're both falling and footsteps of
greatness and I was like [ __ ] we took a
picture and I was like then I started
thinking about him differently like
trying to under trying to reconcile the
policies that I didn't like with a guy
who I thought you know you can't you
can't do that job you can't shake that
many hands and have absolutely no like
you know he I liked him he won you oh
it's a weird charisma that they have
which enables them to get people to vote
for that charisma he well that was
charismatic that blind but it wasn't
just that you know okay so then right
after that he finishes he gives a talk
where he talks about how the Union might
not survive like if that was the premise
of the any points to Abraham Lincoln
there was a time in our life when the
Union wasn't certain and I'm thinking to
myself she's saying that the Iraq war is
the same thing as the u.s. Civil War I'm
thinking that guy's crazy
and he goes and my my administration has
an agenda for peace and he looked right
at me and like my mouth dropped open and
I was just like you just did yeah yeah
right and I was like he knows I can tell
he's lying so but I just kind of stood
there and then and then they after his
speech was over you know my mind is just
racing and the council by the way was
the President's Council on service and
civic participation and was a every
president in the United States except
for which the one who had the heart
attack
Jimmy carved no car didn't have a heart
attack
Martha meant living presidents no no no
no like in all of the history of the
presidency United States the guy was at
after Kennedy's heart attack
one thing about Kennedy's heart attack
in there but but they've all had some
call to service right you know I Kennedy
said ask not what you can do for your
country that's not what your country can
do for you ask what you can do for your
country
yeah so this was Bush's moment to do
that so anyhow it so he finished his his
talk in there like oh let's have a
picture by the HMS resolute so we all
get behind the desk
and I stand right next to him with my
mouth kind of like overlapping is here
behind his shoulder kind of thing and
I've been doing a television series in
Canada and they actually worked out my
schedule so I could fly back and do this
thing and the Canadians who were not so
happy about the Iraq adventure we're
like you tell that man we don't want him
to do this you tell him not to do this
and the director said I worked around
the schedule for you it took me a few
hours and it's and it affected things
the your obligation to me for helping
you go be there is remember that good
thing evil is what happens when when
good men do nothing so I'm standing
there the whole time I'm thinking like
I'm a good man I have to do something
what am I gonna do what am I gonna do so
I whisper in his ear I didn't whisper
what I said it was there I said mr.
president I'm working with some good
Canadians who were very worried and I
look forward to going back there
tomorrow and telling him what you said
here today about having an agenda for
peace and I said it hard and he snapped
his head around he looked me right in
the eye and he goes I am down on bended
knee every day praying for it and I was
and I said I believe you it was power
wow it was powerful so like when he
snapped his head around it wasn't he was
agreeing with you he liked me mr. hissed
he knew exactly what I was saying I was
saying you you don't care about peace
now and send an envoy you're not trying
to get Saddam out of there peacefully
you want a fight you have 150,000 people
in Qatar and you want to fight and I
know you want to fight in your and your
vice president wants to fight and
Halliburton is gonna make a trillion
dollars and like this is not right you
have not done everything if presidents
say that it's a last resort it should be
a last resort and in my little subtle
thing I was saying this isn't last
resort and you're not doing everything
you should be doing and he snapped his
head around he's like you little [ __ ]
yeah I am doing everything I can't be
doing and I'm like oh my god and I swear
I thought all the way back my head is
exploding like okay so if he believes
what he believes what does that mean
what does it mean if this guy will let
you like is he you know has he been
drugged
did you believe in that moment that he
believed that he was absolutely he
absolutely was not lying and not being a
politician like it's a God way no way no
way he was I was questioning his soul I
was questioned I was I was standing I
was God standing in judgment of a man at
that moment and he was like I'm doing
the right thing and you and how dare you
it's amazing that he reacted with
emotion because that's obviously emotion
and a guy like that in that position
you'd think like you know you you
deal with CEOs who are just business and
non-emotional and cut off but that's an
emotional well think of it I mean even
if it was a vendetta for his dad or
revenge for his father's like the fact
that he's in Kennebunkport and so now
I'm still in power and it's like kind of
biblical even if it's you know oil
strategic that we that maybe on some
level there's people have done the math
and our civilizations gonna crumble if
we don't control the well I know
whatever rationale there there there is
for it this was he you know my buddies
running for City Council right now
mm-hmm
my agent is acting running for City
Council and we're talking last night
it's like that's actually kind of a
brave thing it's a brave thing because
you know you get the council gets what
on a half a million dollars to work with
or two million dollars or something and
then you're making decisions and before
now all of a sudden once you get elected
it's an office of public trust like the
possibility for malfeasance is there the
possibility of being falsely accused of
malfeasance by opponents is there all of
a sudden like your cheese is on the line
well that's for City Council and so this
guy now the president United States you
know he didn't win the election like we
now have two people two presidents who
didn't win their elections who serve in
our country it's in the recent memory
and it's shocking but when he was
president he's it's do you mean Trump -
yeah of course you do you think that's
the heat he won fair and square do you
think it's intellect for college is she
like they should take the electoral
college away I guess because he did with
a the people hate Trump he did win it
fair and square
yeah he wasn't giving he didn't in that
see he worked the system and the same
one motion one he was square two because
the budget Supreme Court chose to stop
the recount that's our that's law I mean
I cried the day al gore was sitting in
Congress and all the Congressional Black
Caucus was coming up and he was
affirming the votes or whatever it is
with the with the presidential like the
electoral receiving the whatever that
moment is and and they were like you won
the election and this is wrong and he's
like we live in a country with laws and
you know if you don't have a second you
have to sit down and he was like
gaveling these people who were defending
it nobody even saw this I was in my
house cry
when I was watching this so no he
believes in the rule of law according to
the rule of law George Bush was the
prize in the United States the fact that
his father had appointed a couple of
those Supreme Court justices and his
brother was the governor of the place
where that like no to speak I mean all
the in Trump he did what and I think you
ought to call it stinks and it should go
away but he but he did win it fair I
mean we have to say he wanted according
to the way the system is set up like
there were no extenuating circum yeah
yeah I mean there might be with the
Russia stuff yeah I would think that by
now if that were the case then oh no no
it's not a thing you're gonna ever be
able to prove if I show you a picture of
Hillary and aborted fetus mm-hmm and
then you leave here and tomorrow you're
sitting somewhere else how much did that
picture mean to you do you even remember
it is it in your consciousness who knows
those people showed footage they they
you know one poor man watching these
hearings they they they fuel that thing
so that the conversation wasn't about
what it should be about did I think
Democrats are ridiculous for saying they
know it didn't cost the election the
election was won on a razor-thin margin
so yes to a constitutional standard
based on the Electoral College and the
fact that he took the oath of office
Donald Trump is the president United
States but you know what I live in a
state with where 3 million more people
voted you know for her than him and
people like well that's just on the you
know well if you take away New York you
know no you don't take away New York in
California you don't take them away I
live in New York my friends live in New
York my fellow citizens are in LA Mike
California Mike I'm a Californian and
all my vote should count yeah so I just
think the electric college is a shitty
system but it is what it is I don't like
it any more than anybody else it should
be it should be looked at there's a lot
of things that should be looked at I
think we should have a new
constitutional Congress they're voting
on that right the constitutional
convention you have to wrap up was
trying to say about because I could talk
to you all day Ray I love the fact let
me take your mind before we promote by
the way what he's gonna say yeah because
I've seen obviously a binge stranger
things season 2 and that's one of those
things that's a risky thing to take I
think because the season one was so well
received it could fly and it did
I've actually thought season two was
better which is rare but like then it's
not risky because you knew it was gonna
be because the audience wants more right
so you're participating and giving
people what they want so your carrot
sucks it's risky well you know what's up
your character is dating Winona Ryder's
character now I'm not gonna give any
spoilers because they're people who
haven't seen it but there's this scene
now they've seen the whole thing I keep
coming back to the year scene I think it
might be my favorite scene of the whole
season where you're sitting there with
your character sitting there with Winona
and you're going and now look at me I'm
dating Joyce buyer yeah and it's like
this quintessential nice guy who's
dating over the head you know nothing
good is gonna come of it and when no one
has even got this like oh yeah it's like
cringy but you feel for the guy cuz he's
just been in the friend zone sad that
she needs that to be reassuring yeah but
it is reassuring yeah and that you know
yeah I look at you like that yeah you
just do such a good job of playing this
like nice justjust nice friend zone good
die I love her to death and but then you
also get like hey I love Kenny Rogers
[Laughter]
Kennard Kenny Rogers fan is like you
know that's gonna be a choice he's just
a guy who's like he really wants to
relate but he's never quite he's always
just a little too nice he's just a
little outside of what's going on and
it's just you do an awesome awesome
thank you so much for the job and I prom
and thank you